Plants aren’t always operating at 100 percent efficiency
In fact, in bright sunlight
they ramp down the efficiency of photosynthesis
to avoid damage to key molecules.
The drop off is abrupt
the plants need to protect themselves.
But getting back up to speed is slow.
Like the way your eyes slowly adjust
after entering a dark room.
It’s estimated that 20% of plant productivity
is lost to this slow ramp up
in response to rapid changes in light.
That’s a lot of corn not made.
Where does all this variation in light come
from?
From clouds passing over the sun,
from wind blowing leaves around,
casting moving shadows from other plants,
even their own leaves.
In fact, from the point of view of a leaf,
even the change in the angle of light as the sun moves
through the sky
can cause abrupt variations in light
Researchers wanted to see if they changed this curve
the speed at which a plant returns to full efficiency
if that could have a big impact on productivity.
By swapping a few genes from one plant to another,
they were able to change
photosynthetic recovery time.
Plants with these genetic changes recovered
about 15 percent of their productivity—
giving them bigger, broader leaves,
taller stalks, and more heft in general.
Since the mechanisms targeted in this research
are common to a large swath of plants
this could be tested in all kinds of crops.
For soybean breeders, a 2 % increase in yield is huge.
So, what would a 15% increase in yield give us?
Use less land for agriculture?
Feed more people?
Maybe both.